depuis quelques temps un jeune garçon de
12 ans vient véritable cauchemar
rappelle de cette mère de famille qui
affirme que son enfant est harcelé à
l'école depuis plusieurs jours chaque
jour paraissent élève de 6e et atteint
d'épilepsie et victime de violences de
la part de ses camarades des violences
aussi bien verbales que physiques selon
sa mère au début c'était des insultes
après des bousculades des étranglements
ils l'ont poussé dans les escaliers ses
parents qui dénoncent l'inaction de
l'établissement pour protéger leur
enfant et qui ont porté plainte contre
le collège l'ont récemment retrouvé avec
le visage tuméfié
ces images terribles qui ont bouleversé
de nombreux Français la France sous le
choc après la maltraitance à l'école
d'un enfant de 12 ans handicapé le cri
du cœur de Farès et sa maman dans TPMP
[Musique]
je suis très très heureux de rencontrer
Sarah et de rencontrer Farès bon enfin
c'est quoi ton parfum
merci d'être avec nous en tout cas
en septembre dernier Farès entre en 6e
au collège Jules Verne de Carcassonne tu
as 12 ans mon fils à 11 ans
et tu as un handicap épileptique donc tu
rentres dans une classe Ulysse
expliquez-nous déjà le cas de Farès
et il a été diagnostiqué la syndrome de
dose et depuis ça a été un long parcours
médical
et tous les il a pris en retard il n'a
pas été à l'école très tôt et par
rapport à ce retard là il a été
scolarisé très tard et il a été mis en
classe Ulysse
c'est une classe voilà pour les enfants
un peu plus en difficulté ou un handicap
ou
c'était sa première année donc dans ce
collège oui
concrètement est-ce qu'il peut faire
régulièrement des crises phares où ça va
de mieux en mieux ça va te le dire avec
le traitement de tout va bien
c'est la bonne nouvelle ça c'est la
meilleure bonne nouvelle déjà on va
passer maintenant
on reste mais c'est vrai que c'est
depuis qu'il est petit qui faisait
demi-heure
maintenant ça
allait mieux c'est ça alors
il va donc il rentre dans cette école
les premiers jours comment ça se passe
très stressant et très stressé pour nous
c'était un nouveau environnement
au début ça les deux premiers jours ça
allait et après ça a commencé tout
doucement et rentre de l'école il est
content il a des potes et tout va bien
de la primaire donc il était content
c'était un nouvel endroit d'accord c'est
vous qui allez le chercher qu'il amène
en fait il a droit un transport scolaire
s'il amène le matin qu'il le récupère le
soir et moi je le récupère entre midi et
deux donc
au départ ça se passe bien donc les deux
premiers jours il est content oui et
qu'est-ce qui se passe à partir du du
troisième jour j'ai envie là ça a
commencé par des insultes
pourquoi pourquoi Farès
tout de suite pas tout de suite non et
l'ami du temps avant de raconter
comment quand il rentre de l'école il
est rentré paraissait un peu normal
après ça se passait surtout sur la
Playstation parce que ça a été aussi à
travers les réseaux
on aurait pu se retrouver
et donc et là vous voyez comment vous
avez vu que ça se passait mal au début
quel était le premier signal le premier
signal ça a été et il a commencé en
inventer des maladies pas à l'école
c'est ça
commence le soir avant d'aller au lit et
commencer ça va maman j'ai un peu mal au
ventre j'ai un peu mal à la tête et le
matin dès que le réveil sonné j'ai mal
au ventre je suis pas bien je peux
rester ici ou si une de ces sœurs
n'avait pas école il a combien de frères
et il a deux sœurs d'accord
elle est pas ils sont pas du tout dans
les établissements c'est trois
établissements différents
et donc au départ il vous dit bon j'ai
pas envie d'aller à l'école je me sens
pas bien au départ vous dites bon et
c'est juste parce qu'il a pas envie
d'aller à l'école comme voilà comme
parfois
je l'ai gardé avec moi si tu penses
c'est pas grave tu as deux heures de et
après j'ai commencé à vouloir le forcer
mais c'est quand je suis rentré dans le
forcing avec lui que là il a commencé à
s'énerver à se renfermer sur lui-même et
ça là vous êtes dit il y a un problème
je me suis dit il y a un problème donc
là qu'est-ce que vous avez vous avez
essayé d'interroger Farès ou bien vous
avez essayé d'aller voir peut-être les
gens mon fils d'accord j'ai interrogé
mon fils et là il a commencé à me dire
oui on m'insulte à l'école
voilà d'accord et il m'a dit voilà il y
a son méchants donc ça va des insultes
ça insulte le père la mère et après ça
va je casse à l'indicapé
donc ces élèves de 6e c'est les élèves
de sa classe non c'est pas des élèves du
Lys d'accord c'est quoi c'est des élèves
qu'on conclure en cours de récré quand
ils sont ça d'accord c'est pendant les
pauses c'est ça oui entre un interclass
aussi d'accords
quand il vous dit ça est-ce que vous
prenez ça tout de suite au sérieux vous
êtes dit ça arrive tout de suite pour
les insultes oui on a parlé avec ses
camarades il faut pas ils se sont
excusés on leur a dit faut pas insulter
il faut le laisser tranquille mais quand
vous avez été voir les camarades non
juste au téléphone sur les réseaux j'ai
dit stop il faut arrêter d'accord il
vous a désigné ce qui était les
responsables de ces insultes vous leur
avez vous leur avez parlé sur les
réseaux et vous comptez quoi oui
excusez-nous ça va s'arrêter d'accord
voilà donc là vous êtes vous dites bon
ça va se calmer le lendemain voilà je me
suis dit c'est des enfants ça se passe
en cours de récréation ça va se régler
entre eux le lendemain quand il retourne
à l'école il se passe quoi j'arrive à
midi pour récupérer mon fils et il y a
un feu rouge devant le collège et je
m'arrête au feu rouge et vous savez il y
a tous les enfants donc je cherche mon
fils et de là je vois mon fils qui se
fait étrangler par un autre enfant et il
touche tout le sol il est surélevé comme
ça
la CPE et surveillant j'ai commencé à
hurler mondial avec tous les enfants n'a
pas vu
donc je suis revenu à 14h j'ai appelé le
papa entre-temps donc retrouvé à 14h
devant le collège
ils nous ont dit que c'était interdit de
rentrer sans rendez-vous donc la CPE et
le surveillant en prime aux coordonnées
et ils nous ont pas rappelé
rien du tout non vous avez pas essayé
d'appeler les parents de de l'élève qui
a je connais pas les parents d'accord
vous avez pas essayé d'appeler même pour
dire voilà non non moi je me suis dit ça
se passe dans le dans l'établissement il
faut que ça se règle dans
l'établissement vous l'avez parlé au
petit quand il était en train de
nettoyer vous l'avez dit il faut arrêter
sais pas comment vous jouez mais c'est
pas un amusement donc là c'est la
première grosse alerte c'est la première
grosse alerte ouais donc vous faites des
signalements au collège quand après
cette après cette événement est-ce que
voilà il vous rappelle il vous disent on
va essayer de faire que les choses se
passent mieux ou pas du tout non à ce
moment-là non il a fallu d'une autre
altercation alors on va en parler
justement parce que
le lendemain est-ce que ça continue ou
bien il rentrait il se met dans le
silence d'accord là je le récupère à
midi je dis est-ce que tout se passe
bien il me dit oui il me dit oui les
élèves devant je leur ai demandé aux
camarades devant le collège ils m'ont
dit oui le fait que vous soyez venu avec
le papa ça a calmé un peu ça apaisé des
choses
ton petit à petit les choses vont
empirer il se fait taper insulter
étrangler comme vous dites ça continue
ça continue donc ça continue au bout de
combien de temps ça a repris après cette
première événement après ce qu'il y a
des coupures pendant les vacances
heureusement fin d'année avec son père
on a eu la bonne idée de lui acheter un
téléphone portable
on lui a donné le téléphone et on lui a
dit s'il y a quoi que ce soit nous on
t'autorise à nos téléphones très bien
voilà
donc
là qu'est-ce qui se passe ensuite parce
que
la semaine dernière mercredi la violence
est montée d'un cran la semaine d'avant
aussi il a été qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
le mardi d'avant il a été enfermé dans
les toilettes d'accord
ils se sont mis à lui mettre des coups
de poing dans le ventre et chacun
d'entre eux se motiver allez allez et ça
enfermé dans les toilettes et il a pris
le téléphone il a pris son papa qui
était au travail et son papa est arrivé
et venu secourir son fils
parce qu'il lui a dit allô papa vite je
suis en femme aux toilettes on m'a taper
ce qui s'est passé en fait pour que
c'est toi et c'est quoi pendant la terre
cour il vient te voir et ils se mettent
à t'embêter oui c'est ça j'étais parti
voir j'étais parti aller voir mon copain
et il commence à me dire dégage donc moi
je lui dis non et eux ils ont pris sa
communication donc moi j'ai décidé
d'aller aux toilettes pour pour aller
aux toilettes et donc eux ils sont venus
ils ont commencé à me taper à m'insulter
il s'est pris juste deux heures de colle
c'est tout
incroyable elle t'a répondu quoi
moi tout expliquer elle les a juste
convoqués les
c'est tout
non on est tous très ému très ému oui
non entre le moment où il a été aux
toilettes pour appeler son papa c'était
la récréation oui il est pas venu tout
de suite son papa il a mis combien de
temps pour arriver et personne
s'inquiétait de savoir où il était
Damien à peu près même pas 5 minutes
donc il est à côté en fait oui donc
c'est quand même fou qu'on laisse comme
ça
pas de mots en fait
juste
là c'est le premier vraiment gros gros
événement sordide j'ai envie de dire et
derrière la semaine dernière là on a
tous vu les images et là je vous dis on
a été je vous jure moi j'avais quand je
vois ça après on va dire encore Hanouna
moi j'aurais envie d'aller à l'école là
même moi de Farès et de d'aller voir les
parents et de de de crier assez fort de
faire un de faire vraiment une action
parce que et même auprès du corps
enseignant moi quand j'ai vu des photos
de de Farès franchement je suis désolé
moi je vous dis et bravo d'ailleurs je
voudrais dire bravo à vous et votre mari
parce que vous avez eu le bon
comportement je suis pas sûr que je
l'aurais eu je vous le dis je suis pas
sûr que je l'aurais eu et bravo à vous
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là
au moment à l'interclasse quand j'étais
en train de descendre
il y a des quatrième ils étaient
derrière moi pendant que mes copains
m'appelaient ils ont dit c'est qui Farès
ils m'ont montré que c'était moi et donc
après j'ai senti un comme poussé et on
m'a poussé dans l'escalier
la violence après l'histoire des
toilettes
[Musique]
là
comment vous apprenez ça parce que là
forcément il
qu'est-ce qui se passe qui le récupère
alors moi c'est une élève que je suis
ami avec sa maman qui
m'a contacté pour me dire que mon fils
était au sol 25
quand on vous dit ça ah oui après moi je
me suis imaginé bien sûr mais même quand
on voit les photos mais vous êtes donc
là ça reste il est en son qu'est-ce
qu'il a eu comme il a eu la paupière du
bas ouverte et une fracture du nez
vous allez forcément en direct avec
l'école l'école vous a appelée non mais
arrêtez
incroyable rien donc là il est pas pris
en charge quand il est blessé qu'est-ce
qui se passe il le laisse je suis arrivé
moi il y avait déjà les pompiers
d'accord
donc là vous arrivez avec votre mari lui
il était au chantier à son travail et je
l'ai contacté d'accord et là
vous arrivez moi je suis arrivé
dans quel état
partout et dès qu'il m'a vu je me
rappelle c'est cri maman et en fait il a
eu un relâchement et là il a tout vidé
il s'est mis à pleurer
forcément là il y a les pompiers qui
sont là vous allez voir la directrice de
l'établissement la CPE quelqu'un
le directeur ce matin
il y avait du monde après je me rappelle
pas exactement qui et j'ai commencé à
hurler la personne qui m'a appelé
et est-ce que vous allez les voir
ensuite vous leur dit écoutez quand on
menace notre enfant à l'école on espère
qu'il est en sécurité on peut pas avoir
tous les jours un drame donc là vous
allez pas vous n'allez pas les voir les
pompiers sont sont partis et moi j'ai
suivi le camion de pompier moi je suis
mon fils mais juste parce que je pense
que la question tout le monde se pose il
est 21h07 on est en direct dans TPMP
vous avez tous vu ces images de Farès
vraiment qui nous ont bouleversé il est
avec nous aujourd'hui j'ai eu je l'ai
pris dans les mois tout à l'heure j'ai
eu un coup de coeur pour lui vraiment et
c'est vrai que voilà on voit on a tous
vu ces images et
aujourd'hui ça reste
on a on pense tous à lui on se dit tous
est-ce que il y a le directeur
d'établissement est-ce que ça professeur
est-ce que la CPE vous a appelé derrière
ce drame le mercredi après-midi j'ai le
directeur qui m'a appelé ma première
question ça a été
trois personnes m'appeler voilà il m'a
dit que c'était pas le protocole
est-ce que vous lui avez dit là ça fait
je commence à en avoir ralcu qu'on
puisse aller à l'école et quand je le
dépose à l'école je sais pas dans quel
état je vais le retrouver le soir
trouver des solutions
et j'avais un niveau ce matin alors
qu'est-ce que vous a dit ce matin ce
matin je suis arrivé j'ai trouvé
la police de vol pour taille ce qui m'a
un petit peu après on est rentré on a
parlé surtout de Farès parce qu'il
m'avait demandé que si je voulais te
mettre Farès je devais faire un courrier
pour dire que c'est moi qui ai dit
scolarisé
après un soir ça c'est ils m'ont donné
des devoirs on dit de prendre le temps
comme je voulais pas donner le courrier
et
c'était ils m'ont dit de réfléchir et de
le tenir au courant voilà
on va en parler après de réfléchir à
quoi réfléchir savoir si je laisse Farès
dans ce collège ou c'est lui qui doit
partir
mais on fait quand on fait cette
émission je vous dis on devient fou on
se dit le pays marche à l'envers dans
tout donc
tout on marche à l'envers partout et
donc est-ce que on a su qu'il y avait
poussé
le collège qui l'a poussé dans les
escaliers
là pour le moment donc on a jamais su
que c'était où ils ont rien
à l'école ou pas du tout il y a des
caméras mais l'endroit où Farès est
tombé n'est pas filmé comme par hasard
c'est incroyable c'est toujours comme ça
vous avez remarqué qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y a quelqu'un qui tombe à l'école
les caméras
c'est dans un angle mort non mais c'est
toujours et donc on sait pas de qu'il
s'agit non pour le moment il y a une
enquête à quoi je sais pas du tout eux
ils sont tranquilles parce que ça reste
c'était il a dévalé combien de marches
plus de 7
beaucoup plus grave
déjà c'est grave mais ça aurait pu être
beaucoup plus grave donc là le directeur
d'établissement il vous a dit voilà
votre fils s'est fait pousser dans les
escaliers merci madame de venir vers
vous comment on fait pour le virer du
lycée et du collège c'est ça en fait
en résumé
il nous gêne comment on fait pour le
virer de vacances et garder de ne pas
pousser parce que c'est une enquête en
cours
les toilettes c'est pareil aussi c'est
pas et l'étranglement ils sont enfermés
et donc il vous a dit vous réfléchissez
vous regardez si vous laissez vous les
laissez donc en fait il vous fait une
fleur il dit je vais le garder dans
l'établissement voilà même mais
vous accompagnera on vous accompagnera
où non mais c'est non mais c'est
incroyable qu'est-ce que vous avez
répondu à ça moi j'ai un point
je fournais pas de courrier j'écris pas
de courrier comme quoi j'ai
quand est-ce que vous avez pris la
décision de mettre
de mettre des photos sur les réseaux de
mettre les photos sur les réseaux ça a
été
une fois que j'ai pris les photos et que
j'ai parce que moi je réalise pas moi je
vois mon fils là mais quand je vois des
gens autour de moi qui sont choqués moi
je réalise pas encore je sais pas si
c'est le fait que c'est encore frais
mais ça a été de suite le lendemain on a
déposé plainte et il y a une réquisition
pour le médecin légiste qu'on a vu mardi
j'ai dit ça j'ai dit depuis le mois de
septembre ils nous ont vu ils nous ont
revu et revu là il faut prendre le
problème par l'école il faut arrêter
tout
d'accord oui Jean-Michel ce qui est
horrible à dire c'est que c'est presque
une chance que Farès était blessé s'il y
a tellement d'autres enfants qui sont
pas baissés ça se voit pas qui seront
ferme sur eux-mêmes qui se finissent par
se suicider donc là heureusement qu'il y
a eu un cri d'alerte et que ça a été
visible qui était maltraité parce que ça
aurait pu se terminer de façon encore
plus dramatique c'est incroyable
aujourd'hui il est retourné à l'école
pas du tout non pas du tout ça reste moi
j'ai envie de te poser une question mon
chéri de quoi tu as envie aujourd'hui
tu as envie de changer d'école tu as
envie de faire quoi
[Musique]
tout à l'heure c'est Farès qui se fait
emmerder mais c'est lui qui doit quitter
l'école non mais je vous jure et qui
sont protégés tu sais tu sais toi tu
sais qu'ils sont ceux qui t'embête
on n'est jamais vus
la maîtresse le directeur la CPE ils
t'ont pas demandé Farès qui sont ceux
qui tombaient
[Musique]
leurs parents c'est tout et derrière ils
ont continué
mais juste ça est-ce que je sais pas
après moi je vous dis parce que j'aurais
fait aussi après bon enfin non moi je
vous dis pas mais bon
on a pas moyen de contacter les parents
de ses élèves aussi
non franchement
il serait manifesté le même
est-ce qu'il le savent
moins que ça pour un élève qui a été
chopé parce que il est fumait une
cigarette ou je ne sais quoi là il y a
même pas il y a même pas le corps qui a
convoqué un conseil de discipline ou
rien on devient fou ici
ce pays par an cacahuète oui
ils ont été identifiés ils sont neufs je
crois il y a un qui est considéré comme
le chef qui a été identifié il y en a un
seul qui a eu deux jours d'exclusion et
qui est revenu l'inspection académique
soutient totalement le responsable
d'établissement et pas vous ils ont fait
un communiqué hallucinant presque qui
reprochait au papa d'avoir été un peu
violent quand il est arrivé enfin le
communiqué hallucinant pour le moment il
y a rien je suis le papa moi pour moi il
a pas été violent parce qu'on a rien non
plus non mais je te le dis moi je suis
le papa je te dis la vérité ça se passe
pas comme ça bien sûr le communiqué est
fou et c'est pas comme ça mais qui ne
vous soutiennent pas du tout quoi ils
disent qu'il y a une
voilà donc voilà une procédure interne
est en cours pour traiter la situation
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui va
se passer moi je on va contacter le
directeur de l'école on va savoir
et la rectrice on va voir ça demain
voilà parce que c'est pas c'est pas les
les c'est voilà oui alors juste ça
qu'est-ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui
là dans les prochains jours c'est le
commissariat d'accord des auditions
avoir la conclusion du médecin légiste
voir un pédopsychiatre alors là tu vas
pas à l'école en ce moment
la semaine prochaine tu vas pas à
l'école est-ce que tu veux rester avec
moi toute ici tu restes
en plus qui va venir et je peux dire que
mon fils c'est une terreur
je te dis la vérité il va venir avec toi
tu vas voir non mais c'est tu vois il va
pas rigoler il doit rester avec moi la
semaine prochaine un peu oui
tu te ramènes lundi
par contre moi je comprends rien à
l'école donc je pourrais pas te faire
travailler
il m'a fait rigoler quand on quand il
arrive
[Musique]
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci à
demain